Longmire thrilled fans with its depiction
of life out west. Season after season,
secrets about the residents of its
small town are revealed. In the end,
all of them come crashing together,
creating one majorly compelling drama.
Let's catch up with its talented cast and
see what trails they're heading down now.
Robert Taylor completely embodies the
small town, cowboy-like Sheriff Longmire.
His performance is as powerful as it is nuanced
— you'd think he grew up alongside the likes of
John Wayne and Clint Eastwood. Fun fact: He's not
American at all! Taylor is actually Australian,
and should absolutely get an
award for fooling everyone.
Since starring on Longmire, Taylor has been
busy living life off-screen in Melbourne,
Australia. His Instagram is filled with
pictures of him getting beers with friends,
rooting on the Dodgers, and traveling.
He even made a trip back to Wyoming.
If you miss watching the Sheriff on screen, you
can see Taylor as Dr. Heller in the 2018 film
The Meg, or as Reverend Covern in
the "Down from Dover'' episode of the
delightful Dolly Parton's Heartstrings.
Anyone associated with Dolly while also
living his best life surrounded by
friends and family is doing it right.
The will-they-won't-they relationship between
deputy sheriff Vic Moretti and Walt Longmire
features throughout the entire series.
And while they decide to live together,
their past relationships never allow
them to fully commit to one another.
This badass detective is played by
the equally awesome Katee Sackhoff.
Moretti is tough, layered, and intelligent, much
like the other characters Sackhoff portrays.
Since her time on Longmire, Sackhoff has been
continuously working — often in major franchises.
In the Arrowverse, she plays Amunet Black on
The Flash. She also wields the power of her
voice playing various characters on Robot Chicken.
But she is perhaps best known as Bo-Katan Kryze.
Sackhoff originally only played her on the
animated Star Wars: The Clone Wars series,
but Dave Filoni and Jon Favreau decided to bring
Bo-Katan to life in season two of The Mandalorian,
inviting Katee Sackhoff along for the ride.
"Some of us serve a higher purpose."
If you're looking for even more of Sackhoff's
brilliance, look no further than Netflix.
She stars as Niko Breckinridge on the
sci-fi thriller series Another Life.
It's safe to say that this hard working woman
and friend of Baby Yoda is already a legend.
A resident of the Cheyenne reservation,
owner of The Red Pony, and accused killer,
Henry Standing Bear is a
longtime friend of Walt Longmire.
The connection between the two, paired with
Lou Diamond Philips' engaging portrayal,
made this character one of the
most prominent pieces of the show.
Philips is not new to the Hollywood scene.
In 1987, he received rave reviews for his
portrayal of Ritchie Valens in La Bamba. His
career continued to thrive with a Tony Award
nomination for The King and I, and a Golden
Globe nomination for Stand and Deliver.
Since the finale of Longmire,
Philips' success has known no bounds.
He's actually a world-class poker player,
frequently playing in major tournaments. Guess
his stoic persona as Henry Standing Bear comes
in handy even beyond Longmire. Even though he
hasn't managed to win big at the World Series of
Poker yet, you never know how the chips will fall.
While you wait for his epic victory, you can catch
him on the Fox series Prodigal Son as Gil Arroyo.
If Cassidy Freeman looks familiar, it's
because you probably remember her as Tess
Mercer on the hit show Smallville. After
her tenure on the Superman drama ended,
she stepped into the shoes of Cady Longmire.
Cady, or Punk as she's affectionately known,
is a lawyer, Sheriff Longmire's daughter, and
Branch's girlfriend. Henry's arrest sends her
career in a new direction as a public
defender for members of the reservation.
The series ends with her following
her father's sheriff path.
Freeman is a woman of many talents. She's
in an indie rock band with her brother,
called The Real D'Coy. She's also politically
and socially active, volunteering her time in
support of Jon Ossoff during the 2020 election.
On screen, she's kept busy with roles on the big
screen in 2021's The Forever Purge and on the
small screen in HBO's The Righteous Gemstones.
"God, I have hitched my wagon to a
force for good. Ain't I lucky ladies?"
"Yeah. Lucky."
Freeman absolutely shines in every role she
tackles and will likely continue to do so.
Bailey Chase is Branch Connally,
an affluent and ambitious detective
and the on-again-off-again boyfriend of
Cady Longmire. In a tragic turn of events,
soon after Branch is kicked off the
force, he's killed by his own father.
Like his character, Chase played football
at Duke University on a scholarship.
Luckily for us, he became an actor, and
has been working steadily for years.
After playing the disgraced deputy, he
joined the casts of 24: Legacy, Twin Peaks,
and S.W.A.T. He also reunited with his Longmire
castmate A Martinez on Queen of the South.
Chase's frequently updated Instagram is
particularly fun for Longmire fans to peruse. It's
filled with adorable pictures of his family, pets,
travels, and passions. Take a closer look, and
you'll discover his handle is @branchlives. Turns
out, he loves Branch Connally as much as we do.
A member of the Cheyenne reservation's tribal
police force, Officer Mathias is a
frequent thorn in Longmire's side.
"It's a bit over the top to cuff him."
"Well he didn't have permission
to operate on the Rez."
Mathias is a bit of an enigma,
forcing the audience to constantly question
if he's working towards good or bad aims.
This uncertainty leads to an incredibly nuanced
and dynamic performance from Zahn McClarnon.
As a Native American actor of Lakota
descent, McClarnon is part of a small
minority of working indigenous actors. UCLA's
"Hollywood Diversity Report" revealed only
0.5 percent of top film roles were played by
Native American actors as recently as 2019.
Even though the industry should be
more inclusive across the board,
McClarnon's casting as Officer Mathias is
enormously important and forward-thinking.
McClarnon's career is filled with
unique and interesting roles.
He played Hanzee Dent in the second season
of Fargo and the critically acclaimed role
of Akecheta on Westworld. In 2021, he'll
appear as William Lopez on Marvel's Hawkeye.
McClarnon is breaking barriers for indigenous
actors and is kicking butt while doing it.
A seemingly bumbling addition to the team, Deputy
Archie "the Ferg" Ferguson is just a diamond in
the rough. His relationship with Longmire
is filled with heart and mutual admiration.
When Ferguson tries to resign, he gets one
of the series' most heartbreaking lines:
"I know I was a favor. I only got hired
'cause you were helping out my dad."
The strong bond between him
and Longmire shines through,
as Longmire refuses the resignation,
still seeing potential in Ferguson.
Thank goodness for that, because the show
wouldn't be the same without the Ferg.
Since Longmire, Adam Bartley has appeared on
a plethora of great shows. He plays Carl Brown
on NCIS: Los Angeles, Erik Doyle on Lucifer,
and Duke on This Is Us. Hopefully, he'll soon
play another wonderful series regular role like
Deputy Ferguson. In the meantime, his Instagram
is filled with joy, including his adorable animals
and reunion photos with his Longmire cast members.
Perhaps the most disliked character on
Longmire, business opportunist and Cheyenne
tribal committee member Jacob Nighthorse is
brilliantly portrayed by A Martinez. As with
all the multilayered characters on this show,
there is more to Nighthorse than meets the eye.
Martinez is able to walk the line of being
beyond despicable and remarkably engaging,
creating a stand-out performance in Longmire.
The semi-pro baseball player-turned-actor
began his career in film, but is best known
for his work on soap operas. After wrapping on
Longmire, he found a home again in soap operas,
playing Eduardo "Eddie" Hernandez on NBC's Days
of Our Lives. If his top-shelf acting on Longmire
is any indication of what he brings to Days of
Our Lives, he deserves all the Daytime Emmys.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite TV stars are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.